in order to interact with our robots
moving in the environment we need to
capture the input from the user and
react to it in proper fashion for grits
we have two primary forms of input
number one is keyboard where we use the
WASD keys to actually allow our robot to
move around and get into all sorts of
conky trouble in order to shoot we allow
mouse input for your player so you can
actually see that as I move the mouse
the little mouse cursor moves we don't
actually rotate the upper body of the
robot until you actually fire though so
you can see that as the mouse moves
around my projectiles are of course
following it in suit this allows the
player to move as well as shoot at the
same time now for those of you out there
that do most of your gaming or
programming on a laptop you probably
don't have an external mouse we've also
allowed the ability so that you can play
grits as well and for that rather than
actually aiming your robot to shoot at
things using the mouse we allow you to
use the arrow keys so that pressing in
the specific direction will shoot in
that direction as well and of course
combinations of keys will allow you to
shoot in diagonals